die Angst geht um in Deutschlands Straßen und
damit herzlich Willkommen zu Aktenzeichen XY
Chromosom ungelöst heute beschäftigen uns ein
ganz abscheulicher Fall die Täter sind bereits
identifiziert von den grausamen Verbrechen
die wir Ihnen gerne zur Last legen wollen
fehlt bisher leider jede Spur im Studio begrüße
ich daher die Leiterin der Sonderkommission Mama
bleibt Mama und Papa Papa Frau brechstein
guten Abend [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
Frau brechstein was können Sie uns über
die Täter sagen ja das gefährder-profil
nennt sich gender Gaga der Täter
Kreis umfasst Trans Person Drag
Queens walkners sprachliches Gendern
also eigentlich alles was nicht der
Norm entspricht und wie erkenne ich die ja
wir haben ja einen Phantombild vorbereitet
[Applaus]
ich sage nur abstoßend dummerweise braucht man
für eine Verfolgung in diesem Land immer noch eine
Tat wie könnte diese Tat Aussehen Frau brechstein
nun ja Kinder könnten ja Opfer werden Anna Lesung
einer Drag Queen ja und dann aus dieser Lesung
als Marilyn Söder wieder rauskommen und das
ist natürlich erst der Anfang ja ich sage ihnen
erstmal das selbstbestimmungsgesetz durchkommt
da wechselt hier jeder sein Geschlecht wie
Hertha BSC die Trainer stoppen Sie diese
nein das ist unser Sachverständiger für
Wärmepumpen ich bin universal Gelehrter und
was qualifiziert sie für Gender Themen ich habe
den Regenbogen erforscht das sind ja überhaupt
nicht neutral hören Sie in diesem Gesetz geht
es doch einfach nur darum dass Menschen deren
Geschlechtsidentität nicht dem eingetragenen
Geschlecht entspricht diesen Eintrag ändern
lassen können und zwar ohne sich demütigen
Fragen stellen zu müssen ja gut aber es könnte
ja sein dass ein Mann sich als Frau eintragen
lässt um dann gezielt in Umkleidekabinen von
Frauen einzubringen wie ein Mensch nur so etwas
tun kann tun könnte wir haben ja leider immer
noch keine tat ja deswegen brauchen wir Ihre
Mithilfe gesucht wird eine Tat darum schalte
ich nun zu meiner Kollegin nach Wien Petra
verhält sie gibt es Hinweise in Österreich
guten Abend bisher nicht die Spur eines
Verbrechens aber die Angst geht um danke in der
Schweiz wie sieht's aus gut ob ich auch hier wie
immer alles ruhig aber auch hier Gott die Angst um
vielen Dank ich kann die Kollegen schade immer
noch keine tat aber sollte es zu einer Tat kommen
dann haben wir ja jetzt schon eine Zeugenaussage
und zwar von der bekannten Fußmatten influencerin
monika Gruber wir haben ja mal ein Bild aus ihrem
Webshop der Gender braucht gar nicht es klingelt
habe ich mir schon bestellt ja sie beschreibt
einen Fall in der Therme Erding in der Zukunft
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass die rot-grüne
Mischpoke in einer Nacht der Nebelaktion den
Gesetzentwurf durchfinden wird dass du dir einmal
im Jahr den Geschlecht selber aussuchen kannst in
der Therme Erding mit meine Kleine Nichten der
Damen Umkleide stehen und dann kommt irgendein
Typ rein mit hänge dem Gemächt und baumeln
den Eiern und erzähle meine Nichten dass
es jetzt doch gescheiter ist dass wir uns
im Auto umziehen das ist eine wunderschöne
Tag ja aber sie ist nicht passiert noch nicht
dann müssen wir es weiter auf diese Tat warten
ich esse übrigens Fleisch [Applaus]
bei uns gibt es das Geschlecht das auf dem Tisch
kommt hören Sie sofort auf zu warten es gibt genug
Taten allerdings sind die Trans Personen die
Opfer laut einer Datenerhebung der EU wurde
ein Drittel der Befragten Transpersonen Opfer
von Gewalt oder Gewaltandrohung Entschuldigung
ist das jetzt nicht eine ganz gefährliche
täteropfer Umkehr und warum geht es denn
eigentlich schon wieder um die was ist mit
uns ja sie nur weil eine Minderheit etwas mehr
Aufmerksamkeit bekommt heißt das doch nicht dass
sie weniger davon bekommen haha das kenne ich das
hat mir meine Mama auch gesagt kurz bevor meine
Schwester auf die Welt gekommen ist alles gut
warum reden hier alle über Gefahren die
es gar nicht gibt weil man dafür viel Geld
bekommt internationale Geldgeber haben in den
letzten Jahren über 700 Millionen Dollar für
Anti gender Kampagnen ausgegeben auch der
europäische Adele unter anderem gestalten
wie Beatrix von Storch mischen damit dieser
seltsamen Mischung was beleidigter lieber Wurst
Hans-Georg Maaßen und einem verpassten
Friseurtermin der Abend [Applaus] Gabel
ja das steckt sein ja über Jahrhunderte gaunert
das Vermögen in Kampagnen transfeindlichkeit
finanziert vom Adel dabei ist es
doch vor allem das Adels Gesocks
das sich seit Jahrhunderten fragt
aus welchem Geschlecht ist kommt
Vertreterinnen in dieser nutzlosen
Gesellschaftsschicht Gloria von Thurn
und Taxis darf ihre dümlichen Vorurteile über
alles was normale so aufregt in einer Sendung
des Sexisten Julian Reichelt darbieten und wer
vor langen Jahren einmal ein Gespräch zwischen
kam mit dem Frosch und Miss pegina Muppet
Show erleben durfte und heute reichelt und für
den Gloria sieht der weiß dass die Evolution
den falschen Weg eingeschlagen hat und warum
warum dürfen die warum dürfen die beiden
über Gefahren reden die es gar nicht gibt
weil es auch da viel Geld gibt für diesen gemeinen
gefährlichen Unfug von Frank Gotthardt Milliardär
und Ehrenvorsitzender des Wirtschaftsrates der
CDU in Rheinland-Pfalz schwerreiche finanzieren
die Hetze gegen Klimaschutz transrechte oder
gesündere Ernährung und nur zu einem Zweck um
die Positionen der AFD zu stärken die vor
allem die ideologische Schlägertruppe der
Reichen ist Abschaffung der Gewerbesteuer
Abschaffung der Erbschaftssteuer keine
Steuererhöhung gegen die AFD ist die AFD
eine maxistische Splittergruppe [Applaus]
was vergessen na das Abo und die Glocke
was dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind sehr klug